let's dig in more specifically into what
we expect to happen to premiums in the
cost of health care if the Affordable
Care Act is repealed and the American
Health Care Act Republic hair is past
we've been following the unveiling of
the Republican health care plan and
everything that's followed it's been a
disaster from the beginning it doesn't
make sense mathematically Democrats
don't like it many Republicans don't
like it Trump's so far at least doesn't
want his name on it and Republicans have
actually told people that coverage isn't
really the ultimate goal for example the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Trump appointee Tom Price said that
nobody will be worse off financially
because of the law let's start with that
clip first but I noticed you ducked the
aspect of whether you can guarantee that
nobody will be worse off financials I I
firmly believe that that nobody will be
worse off financially in this in the
process that we're going through
understanding that they'll have choices
that they can select the kind of
coverage that they want for themselves
and for their family not the government
forces right they'll have choices
they'll have choices another White House
official said we shouldn't actually
focus so much on how many people are
going to be covered because what's
important is freedom and access when the
rubber meets the road this is going to
be very expensive for the average and
roll lead we have a new analysis now
from health policy experts which is
determined that the Republican health
care program would cost the average
enroll person an extra fifteen hundred
and forty-two dot 2017 and of course
this might not be fully or even
partially implemented in 2017 by 2020
the figure could be that this plan from
Republicans could cost each enrollee an
additional twenty four hundred dollars
per year and of course that would be
more money for fewer benefits than what
they had or have under the Affordable
Care Act as we've been talking about
more money for less coverage not exactly
a good deal is it Pat of course not I
mean it seems like they're trying to get
ahead of the game by conceding the point
that less people will be covered under
the American health care
act but if premiums continue to rise I
mean what are they going to do in that
instance we know that's been going on
even since the Bush administration and
Obamacare you could argue a slow down
the rate of premium increases but if
they don't solve any of the problems and
10 million people plus lose their health
insurance I mean what leg will they have
to stand on I have no idea I guess just
trying to blame Obamacare in some way
shape or form Tom prices also recently
said that we don't believe that
individuals will lose coverage at all
but in saying those things people won't
lose coverage people won't pay more
price isn't really staying on message
because Gary Cohn Donald Trump's top
economic adviser along with other
Republicans have been stressing it
doesn't matter whether people are not
have coverage here's a quote from cone
two fox news sunday it's not just about
coverage it's about access to care it's
about access to be able to see your
doctor's the number of who's covered and
who is not covered that's interesting
and I know that may make some headlines
but what we care about is people's
ability to get health care and people's
ability to go see their doctor could you
come up with a more incoherent
explanation of what it is that he thinks
should happen and Chris Wallace
responded correctly by saying coverage
is really important if you lose it then
Paul Ryan came out and said to Hugh
Hewitt last week that if fewer people
are covered it actually doesn't matter
here's Paul Ryan we always know you're
never going to win a coverage beauty
contest when it's free market versus
government mandates if the government
says thou shalt buy our health insurance
the government estimates are going to
say people will comply and it will
happen and when you replace that with
we're gonna have a free market and you
buy what you want to buy they're going
to say not nearly as many people are
going to do that that's just going to
happen and so you'll have those those
those coverage estimates we assume
that's going to happen that's not our
goal so which is it is it that no one's
going to lose coverage or is it that it
doesn't matter if people lose coverage
as long as the plan allows for freedom
liberty patriotism and all of that stuff
it's apparently about the total and
unmitigated
liberty and freedom to choose whether or
not to buy things that as a result of
Republican policy you won't be able to
afford doesn't make much sense does it
it is not looking good for the average
enrollee send me your thoughts about
this i'm on twitter at d pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show